some breaking news right now though and
the former Hollywood mogul Harvey
Weinstein has just been sentenced to 23
years in jail for rape and sexual
assault you'll remember Weinstein
convicted of rape also two counts of
sexual assault in New York last month
since 2017 dozens of women have come
forward accusing the 67 year-old of
sexual misconduct including rape though
Weinstein has consistence that
consistently denied any wrongdoing Patty
Calhoun following this one from
Washington DC hi Patti how did all this
unfold today well I think its first
important to remember that this article
about Harvey Weinstein really launched
the me2 movement people who are asking
how is this going to end well we know
how it ends for Harvey Weinstein he's
likely going to die in prison he has
been sentenced to 23 years he's a 67
year old man in bad health let's not
forget he had to go to the hospital for
a heart procedure after he was sentenced
he's now been moved to the prison where
we believe he's had at least one
concussion from a fall so Harvey
Weinstein was facing between 5 to 29
years in prison for those sexual assault
charge criminal charges that he was
found guilty of the judge went with 23
years again he's 67 in bad health this
will likely mean he will die in prison
if he doesn't get any sort of special
treatment and this is Neil - Casey's
facing he's also facing potential
charges in Los Angeles so for the man
who launched the me2 movement apparently
not coming to grips quite yet with what
he is now convicted of doing according
to the Associated Press in court he said
to the judge he doesn't really it was
confused by the rape charge and said
thousands of men are losing due process
I'm worried about this country so that
might have been a factor in why the
judge lovage such a very stiff sentence
on Harvey Weinstein we're not sure more
will come out of what's just been
breaking news out of New York right now
but again Harvey Weinstein launched the
me2 movement people wondered all around
the globe would there actually be
accountability the answer for at least
Harvey Weinstein is yes he's going to
likely die in prison maybe tell us a
little bit more if you don't mind patty
about the me2 movement I
no people will be well aware of it but
how much momentum I guess it gathered as
a result of Harvey Weinstein in the
moment momentum it still heads today
even if it's not totally in the
headlines well I think it's still very
relevant and I think what you saw is the
election of Donald Trump and we saw the
largest protest march in the history of
this country which was the women's March
it was absolutely massive it was across
the globe at across the United States
for sure then you saw some really
dedicated journals come out the New York
Times in The New Yorker Ronan Farrow The
New Yorker and they did this expose an
Weinstein keep in mind he was considered
untouchable in Hollywood he won his
movie studio launch careers won Oscars
he was the big man in Hollywood well
these allegations were that he had raped
dozens and dozens of women and some of
these women very famous women were brave
enough to go ahead and give their names
and so then it went to Twitter and we
saw actresses say if you've actually had
this happen to you if you've been
harassed if you've been assaulted
retweet with me too and it exploded it
was everywhere and all of a sudden it
came to the public consciousness just
how widespread of an issue this is it's
not just in Hollywood we've seen lots of
men in the media be brought down because
of all their own allegations of
impropriety sexual harassment and in
some cases sexual assault you aren't
seen as much though moving to other
industries at least not as publicly but
there is much more awareness of it there
are women who've created a fund so that
they can help lower income women for
such as maids in hotels
be able to get the assistance they need
to be able to propel their own me to
movement so it was the first case it was
by far not the last but it does send a
message to predators out there that
there can be punishment Patti Callahan
with the update on the sentencing of
Harvey Weinstein there Thank You Patti